well i'm joined now from new york by the
united nations secretary general antonio
guetras
very good to talk to you secretary
general thank you very much indeed for
joining us
on sky news and can we start with the
sustainable development goals 17 of them
in total but have they been derailed
the progress derailed by the covid
pandemic
dramatically derailed the the pandemic
has
shown how vulnerable we are vulnerable
in relation to a microscopic virus that
has put on our ease
vulnerable already in relation to
climate change and many other challenges
that we are facing
and the truth is that all the progress
that was being made in the dedication of
poverty and dedication of hunger
and in many other aspects around the
world all that progress
is being put into question in some
aspects we are moving 25 years back
and now we need to enhance our efforts
and we need to take profit
of the huge mobilization of resources
that is being done for the recovery
to make sure that those resources are
applied in line
with those sustainable development goals
to have more inclusivity
more equality more equality more justice
and at the same time more sustainability
in the way we prepare our future we
cannot go back to where we were
we need to try to profit of the recovery
in relation to the covet
to build a more sustainable and
inclusive world but are you worried that
developed nations will not be getting
that message they will concentrate on
their own populations
first and foremost in the recovery in
the developing world
will lose out
that's the problem we are facing now uh
i've asked since the beginning of the
crisis
for the mobilization of a rescue package
of
two digits of the global economy
now the truth is that if you look at the
united states or europe
this was done to rescue their own
economies
but if we look at the developing world
the volume of resources mobilized until
now is much smaller
and on top of that many of them have a
dramatic depth problem
there was a suspension of depth for the
least developed countries this is the
group of the poorest countries in the
world
but we need to have much more debt
relief for developing countries and some
middle income countries
and we need to have a much more relevant
transfer of resources
to those poor countries that are facing
now the impact of the coffee
and the impact in their own economies
and societies
where poverty was already quite dramatic
and where the access to health to
education
and to several other aspects was already
lagging behind in relation to the
developed world
well do you worry then for the future of
multilateralism and
talking through the prism of kovitz
still when we read today for instance
when it comes to a vaccine the developed
countries have
bought up 51 percent of these candidate
vaccines yet represent only 13 percent
of the world's population
they're going to look after their own
populations aren't they
i've just came from a meeting with the
the team of the kovacs
which is the project of a
vaccine seen as a global public good as
a people's vaccine
and i have to say we will be working
hard in order to get the necessary
funding
we have already 2.7 billion with 35
billion
in order to make sure that independently
of the efforts that developed countries
do to
serve the the needs of their own people
that we are able to mobilize
international solidarity for the
developing countries
to also be able uh when a vaccine is
available
to use them for their people and the
reason is clear the the
the argument is obvious uh a vaccine can
be extremely important to
allow for the relaunch of the global
economy
but if it only happens in the north the
south
uh unfortunately uh will um
make uh the cover the the the covet come
back as we have seen
see the covet moves from north to south
from uh
east to west uh there are second waves
being expected so we need to make sure
that we have a vaccine everywhere
if we want to protect our own uh
populations in the developed world
and secretary general while you're with
us i've got to ask you about the dire
dire situation in yemen we know there's
a u.n appeal out for that only raised a
third of the money
so far required we have a a special
report tonight from our special
correspondent alex crawford she's
on the ground there and describes what
you know all about um
the war code of course and now potential
farming just how worried are you about
the situation there
extremely worried we just had today a
ministerial meeting
of a number of countries committed to
yemen
and there are two things that are
essential first we need to push
for the parties of the conflict to agree
on the project that was already
submitted to them of a joint declaration
establishing a global ceasefire
in yemen establishing simultaneously a
set of confidence-building measures from
the economic and social aspects
and starting a political process and
second we need to mobilize the resources
in order for humanitarian aid that is
now
very much below the level that is
necessary for humanitarian aid
to be able to be distributed to a
population in a very dramatic situation
and also asking the parties to the
conflict to facilitate
the excess and distribution if the
resources are made available
but we are in a dramatic situation we
need to put an end to the conflict
we need to make sure that we move into a
political process and at the same time
we need to mobilize resources and to
create conditions for access
to uh support a population that is in a
desperate situation
and if i may say something i was i
commissioned for refugees the yemeni
people was always extremely generous
they were receiving refugees from
somalia coming to their shores
sharing their resources with them even
already with the conflict inside yemen
and always sharing what they had and
what they
had not with the somalis that were uh
seeking uh refuge in yemen so these
generous people
now needs international solidarity